a doctor who says there's a way we could
actually live past 100 find out how on
the next Oprah are you a snake oil
salesman the Angels exist and are they
sending messages help us heal or are you
a reasonable clinician behind the
medical celebrities of Deepak Chopra and
dr. oz is a contentious decades-long
strategy to promote alternative medicine
to the American public how the National
Institutes of Health took an assortment
of mystical therapies from the
fraudulent fringes of the marketplace
and planted them right in the heart of
the American medical establishment is a
story of institutional failure a few
vials of bee pollen thank you very much
and an overdose of political ambition
new schools better health care for our
citizens that's the American dream in
1984 Congress presented a comprehensive
report on fraudulent medicine in America
their conclusion was a scandal con
artists swindled the public out of ten
billion dollars a year untested herbs
and mystical energy therapies filled the
aisles of health stores and the back
pages of disreputable magazines
they preyed on the elderly the desperate
and the terminally ill 50 experts from
leading medical institutions called for
tougher enforcement against a practice
few Americans had even heard of at the
time alternative medicine are you ready
for a president who will turn this
country in a new direction following a
failed presidential bid Senator Tom
Harkin of Iowa thought he'd found both a
cure for his hay fever and a remedy for
American healthcare back in the late 80s
he believed that bee pollen cured his
allergies bee pollen has been studied to
see whether it has any effect on
allergies and the science says that it
doesn't but he believed that it did and
he apparently asked why isn't NIH
putting more money into this we got to
be studying these things there's
tremendous promise here for going out
and finding these natural remedies and
so he created the office of alternative
medicine so it was an office with a
director and he devoted a few million
dollars to that our next speaker is the
director of the new office of
alternative medicine at the National
Institutes of Health please help me
welcome dr. Joseph Jacobs the art of
medicine consists of him using the
patient while nature cures and disease
and my job was to objectively evaluate
whether or not these therapies had a
therapeutic benefit with degrees from
Columbia Wharton and Yale Medical School
dr. Jacobs had all the preferred
credentials of the medical establishment
but as an American Indian Jacobs also
had first-hand experience with
traditional Mohawk herbal remedies that
had been in use for centuries and that
appealed to the alternative community I
had been raised in a certain belief
system that there were other things
besides white man's medicine that were
were important as a medicine man with
establishment credentials Jacob seemed
the ideal candidate to bring alternative
medicine out of the shadows and into
mainstream medical practice but the
office of alternative medicines Advisory
Council had a very different set of
priorities a year before Oprah Winfrey
would make him a household name Deepak
Chopra had been appointed to the Council
dr. David Eisenberg was an expert in
traditional Chinese medicine but the
members appointed by Senator Harkin
presented the most opposition to dr.
Jacobs there was Ralph Moss a writer
fired by sloan-kettering Cancer Center
for misleading the public about
alternative cancer treatments and Garr
Hilton brand who offered diet based
cancer cures from his clinic in Tijuana
Mexico
they were inflamed with this political
power that they had from Harkin and so
they really tried to intimidate the NIH
staff over and me because yeah they
wanted things done in the way they say
and that was it otherwise we were gonna
get senator Harkin on your ass also in
the council was Iowa congressman Berkley
Bedell a close friend of Senator Harkin
Vidal was convinced that cows colostrum
infused with his own blood had cured his
Lyme disease he didn't believe in the
scientific method he wanted to us to go
and look at charts you know rubber-stamp
them in terms of success and to publish
that in the New England Journal of
Medicine and it just didn't work that
way maybe I'm not even thinking this but
charlatans are afraid true charlatans
are really afraid to show themselves in
light of day after two years on the job
dr. Jacobs resigned Harkin and his
political cronies probably wanted
somebody else but they wanted me to do
their bidding and I really couldn't do
that once he was gone the Advisory
Council was free to present its own view
of the future of American medicine
alternative medicine expanding medical
horizons was a landmark report marking
the first time the government had ever
taken a favorable look at medical
practices that had been relegated to the
fringes of American society it was a
total reversal of a 1980s report on
quackery energy medicine homeopathy and
magnet therapy were no longer seen as
the domain of con artists with state
support these treatments and others like
them would be taken out of the shadows
and integrated into mainstream medicine
providing hope for a more effective
lower-cost health care in America the
media jumped on the alternative
bandwagon in the 1990s Publishers
showered new-age healers with magazine
covers and big money book deals the
alternative medicine celebrity was born
in the popular series healing in the
mind veteran journalist bill moyers
thought he saw the future of American
medicine we're on the cusp of a
revolution in medicine as important as
the discovery of antibiotics like
penicillin to witness the coming medical
revolution Moyers traveled to China his
guide in Beijing was dr. David Eisenberg
of the office of alternative medicine
the closest I've ever seen anything to
this is looking at people who claim to
be faith healers
Moyer's and Eisenberg met some of
China's best-known acupuncturists and
herbalists they call this teacher of
Master sure and an elderly man who
claimed to harness a mystical energy
field known as Chi giving him the
strength of six men but that goes
against everything we know and
understand in Western science it defies
the biophysical Lord
Moyer's sympathetic examination of
supernatural medicine set the tone for
today's television healers whose
miraculous claims and occasional state
support are rarely questioned by the
news media is talking to the dead a new
kind of therapy psychic medium John
Edward believes it can be could it help
you someday but while the media saw
medical revolution just around the
corner senator Harkin was frustrated by
what he saw is the slow pace of reform I
asked the director of NIH a few months
ago who's in my office how many
treatments or practices or medicines
they had investigated and validated
since 1992 and I was met with a
deafening silence the answer is none and
yet next year we're putting 13 million
dollars into the office of alternative
medicine one might rightly ask where is
it going and what's happening the
response that harken then enacted in the
Senate was to elevate the status of the
office of alternative medicine to a
national center
he gave it its own line item in the NIH
budget so the United student touch it
and dramatically increase its funding it
raised it at the time to around
50 million dollars and it was raised
quite a bit more in subsequent years
there's this training component of their
funding that has established these
centers and these training programs in
alternative medicine at many leading
medical schools
so what's to me kind of frustrating and
it would be funny if it weren't so
serious is that the training people in
methods that they don't have any
evidence to support if you could
manipulate someone's health by say
waving your hands over them as some
energy healing practices like Reiki and
Healing Touch claim if that were true
that would be remarkable we've never had
any evidence that anything like that is
operating there's any kind of energy
field around humans it's frankly
ridiculous your tissue actually stores
memories and stores emotions a lot of
that read of the burgeoning office of
alternative medicine you know we've kind
of brought everything to the head and
all of a sudden you had people jumping
on the bandwagon medical schools jumping
on the bandwagon
to teach alternative medicine lured by
the promise and prestige of NIH grants
dozens of the most famous hospitals and
medical schools across the United States
now have well-funded centers for
alternative medicine but even as these
centers multiply there are fewer claims
that alternative medicine actually
treats disease the advocates were saying
that cures for cancer hit were hidden
within the alternative medicine universe
and they weren't they weren't as far as
I was concerned about a year ago I was
diagnosed with cancer I had a scan at
7:30 in the morning and it clearly
showed a tumor on my pancreas Apple CEO
Steve Jobs decided to treat his cancer
with acupuncture and a vegan diet while
his cancer continued to metastasize he
apparently had a form of pancreatic
cancer that was treatable most
pancreatic cancer is not treatable and
you it's a terrible terrible form of
cancer and kills most people within a
year he delayed surgery for something
like nine months to a year because he
was trying other dietary treatments
which of course didn't work had he been
treated right away with the most
effective therapy that he might have
been cured that's possible but we'll
never know the answer to that thank you
very much for the welcome
thanks I think did Steve Jobs possibly
doom himself that's been the question
raised this week and he got acupuncture
he got bowel cleanse because he thought
this was an all-natural thing to do and
it ultimately cost him his life how
could such a smart man do such a stupid
thing
following Steve Jobs death alternative
medicine came under intense criticism
the evidence for the safety and efficacy
of complementary approaches is still
very incomplete dr. Josephine Briggs the
director of the recently renamed
National Center for Complementary and
Integrative Health at the NIH responded
to Steve Jobs passing with the first
official admission of the failures of
alternative medicine she wrote when
making treatment decisions unproven
alternative medicine approaches should
not replace conventional medical care
approaches known to be useful or helpful
simply put the evidence is not there and
chem has funded some reasonably design
studies and in every case they've shown
that the alternative modalities they
alternative methods that they were that
they were investigating failed to work
one by one the NIH has long-term
clinical trials began to knock down the
claims of alternative medicine
the press jumped on 18 years of dashed
expectations but the studies were no
impediment for senator Harkin then
serving his 34th year in Congress he
blamed his own creation for the failures
when the purposes of this Center was to
investigate and validate alternative
approaches quite frankly I must say
publicly it's fallen short the focus I
think quite frankly in this Center and
previously the office before it most of
his focus has been on disproving things
rather than seeking out and approving
things it showed to the world really
that Harkin has a really fundamental
misunderstanding of how science works
good science doesn't set out to prove
that something you've already decided
upon works if you already know that it
works you don't need to investigate it I
believe strongly that Americans want
access to health care options and
alternatives that's why I insisted that
integrative medicine get a major boost
in the new health reform law and so
senator Harkin authored the expansion of
alternative medicine into the Affordable
Care Act including the controversial
section 2706 which requires alternative
practitioners to be reimbursed equally
with medical doctors so I am retiring to
the Senate I'm not retiring from the
fight but it seems almost like we've
made this a permanent monument to Tom
Harkin he retired and it would be
terrific if we would also retire this
this National Center but we didn't we
just renamed it it's chief advocate as
has left but it has created its own
pretty extensive group of advocates
people who make money off of getting
funding from an can now NC cih so they
advocate fiercely for its funding to
continue into even increase the science
if something doesn't work we stop
funding and we stop investigating it but
here because we have a dedicated stream
of money going to this National Center
we don't stop
I'm a quack me the fact that the
National Institute of Health has
recently appointed me on a panel for
unconventional and alternative medical
practices and I think what we considered
miracle cures in the past are becoming
the science of today